just months after opening up her fourth
restaurant in LA Lisa Vanderpump is now
weeks away from opening a new lounge in
Las Vegas and six weeks I shouldn't even
really be sitting here why cheer why
magus well because when they ask you if
you want to be in Vegas that's like the
ultimate compliment so I wasn't going to
turn that down they wanted to open a
cocktail garden and I think they saw the
brilliant design you know of Tom Tom and
they wanted something just totally
fabulous so they opposite to me and I
said yes is there any possibility that
we could get a Vanderpump rules Vegas
following the staff of that location or
D that would be like a hot mess
traveling
well maybe I'm sure some of them might
want to work out there so if we get
picked up for another series I'm sure
some of it will filter over there I'm
not sure
well Sheena has said that she would be
willing to work at that place so oh I
have an officer job yet well actually
she would be good because she knows kind
of how I do things so well she's worked
with so many years so maybe yeah she
could there she's got a show that she
loves doing over there he's done a lot
better but like sometimes if we ever had
to bring up our past he's like super
shut off about it you're telling her
basically shut up I don't want to talk
about it okay this season of Vanderpump
rules
I'm not what apologize it's another wild
great season yeah Jackson Britney we saw
their proposal we'll get to see their
engagement party later this season and
then wedding next season yes do you see
this is a long-lasting relationship look
we know Jax is history and normally the
best indication of future behavior is
past behavior unless something really
triggers a huge change and I think grief
and losing someone can do that and I
think the significant loss that he
endured for losing his father look I
don't know I can't predict the future
but right now he seems to be on track so
okay let's keep our fingers crossed and
they'll keep their legs crossed
and you've seen the change in him I have
I have I think is quite committed to her
I really do she's a fabulous girl she
never has like a mean bone in her body
unless no we are leaving that in and
then we have James James he's your
ex-husband he's my father you can't talk
to me about that was I your mother you
took your first steps up King Tiffany's
and he does have a good side and I
really want to show that as an executive
producer on that show it's been very
important to me that we always you know
show the true story but that side of him
where he's supporting his family the way
his family have struggled I mean that's
a lot of responsibility for a young man
and he really has stepped up to it so
hopefully he will grow up does he grow
up this season or will that be seasons
two we still have a lot of vanderpump
season left to watch how would you
describe what is still to come
well there's definitely some surprising
moments that even I said they did not do
that yes they did but it's always been
like that this kind of show you could
actually film 24 you know 7 because it's
not just like a cast that get together
to film right they're always together
and they're always you know that good
times but they is be able don't show the
best owners who definitely show their
work that was so trashy bad apples is
America's perfect reality show
[Music]